[Musique]
oui
crémeuse onctueuse velouté la mousse
crise capelle de l'académie de café de
montréal connaît bien je dirais premiers
manques il y as envie de style de mots
si elle est élue plus traditionnelles
qui produit des grands montets de mou
sur les cardinaux qui mélange le nouveau
ce qu'on appelle plus le micro mousse
[Musique]
crise nous aident à déterminer le
mousseur allait le plus performant en
compagnie de frédérick chabot designer
industriel
si mister allant de 55 à 160 dollars
font partie de notre test
nespresso cuisine à baba delonghi
breville et salt curieusement le salto
n'affiche sur sa voix qu'il est sans fil
mais on constate que ce n'est pas le cas
la compagnie répond que le moose a peut
être retirée de la base est utilisée
ailleurs mais c'est le cas de tous les
moussons pour les test nous avons
utilisé du lait de vache entier 3,25
pour cent un autre pourcentage de gras
ou encore un lait de soya de type
barista fonctionne également le plus
grand le plus que s'est créé meubles
délicieux mesure pour chaque appareil on
a vraiment répéter le même test trois
fois on a pris la température à chaque
fois ça dépasse 60 71
on ne mesurait le ratio les mousses que
j'appelle autant 0 donc au moment où le
produit est prêt tu es très séductrice
et c'est presque une vraie micro mousse
lionne crible comme je dis un peu plus
graves qui restent normalement on frappe
sur le comptoir avec notre fichier on
cherche les deux teams 10e s'ils
possèdent et aussi par contre un mousse
sec avec le les mains sont déçus c'est
un tel choc et un peu plus crémeux plus
contenue dans le gauche finalement ont
tous à mon salaire
je vous s'en étonner oui en fait j'ai
travaillé seulement avec les blues de
vapeur pendant toute ma carrière alors
c'est une pression pour voir que le
quartier de mousser vraiment sin comme
ça alors vas nous indique que la mousse
après un bon moteur doit chauffer le
lève température adéquat dans son entrée
près 60 de tous nos intérêts y passent
le test
si c'est trop chaud c'est cette moins
présents dans le bus mais aussi le goût
âcre ont choisi un porteur finale entre
un peu près 60 à 65 degrés celsius le
lien naturellement un peu plus sucré on
a des appareils qui sont plus efficaces
en termes de transmission de chaleur
donc le nespresso est le symptôme vont
prendre moins de temps à réchauffer la
même quantité de lait nous qu'est donc
pour une cantine n'est identique la
barre et le cuisinant vont prendre un
peu plus de temps que je fais là même
quand ces deux là les personnes qui va
rater son autobus à cause de la vitesse
à laquelle le mou ça fonctionne
chaque modèle est pourvu d'un disque à
ressort ce resort le tourne à grande
vitesse ce qui fait tournoyer les skis
faire entrer de l'air aussi en même
temps violent de l'anguille est
complètement différent qui lui vaut ce
centre est avec sa structure que le
brevet l'itie qui est légèrement
différent 100% en plastique donc
beaucoup plus triste
dans les contrôles on a levé rock et
tout à fait unique un seul bouton
mais on peu avant une mousse très aéré
très ferme ou mousse - henry plus souple
donc pour toi réveiller personne
les avants est absolument silencieux
devant une petite coupe volante douce et
le brevet est un peu plus rien le brevet
il permet de faire mousser 750 mhz et
les litres de lait c'est trois fois plus
que les autres
de plus il possède une poignée d'un
avantage donc les appareils avec
poignées sont vraiment plus pratique 100
km de pouvoir agiter les impôts vraiment
compact et à mousse beaucoup plus facile
je peux même une vraie fille chez de
l'est dans un café parce que sa cuvée
plus grande
le brevet il se nettoie plus facilement
c'est le seul modèle qui va au lave
vaisselle on le cuisine a ici où l'arbre
de transmission est négatif cru j'ai
très peur que il ya des statiques
s'accumulent dans en conclusion nos
experts ont apprécié la mousse de tous
les appareils mais ont dû faire un choix
vraiment salle des fêtes
je pense que je peux pas le dakar avec
chris huhne certains ici comme un
espresso le volume est vraiment petit ce
n'est plus qu'un le matin avoir pour le
café en même temps c'est problématique à
moins de vraiment des petites tasses
donc j'aime beaucoup le volume de celui
là il se lave très bien en plus les
pièces sont solides
c'est un bon appareil c'est le plus
dispendieux de loin si j'ai moins de
budget par contre le
deux langues est excellent aussi sachez
que tous les appareils offre l'option
mousse froide mais nos experts n'y voit
que peu d'intérêt